where we left off in the last video we
saw that things were already starting to
get ugly as early as October of 1789 we
saw the women's March where there were
these suspicions that the Royals were
hoarding the grain so they marched to
Versailles and they essentially stormed
Versailles and forced the Royals forced
louis xvi and marie antoinette to move
back to paris then things continued to
be tense there were uprisings the king
didn't know what to do he obviously
didn't like the situations the people
became more and more suspicious of the
king nobles were leaving the country
they were emigrating out of france the
king and queen themselves started to get
paranoid that gee you know maybe people
have even more radical notions than this
constitutional monarchy
maybe we ourselves should escape so then
we saw in 1791 and let me write this all
down in a timeline so this is we're now
in 1791 and this is a review of the last
video June we saw the Royals try to
escape Royals try escape but they're
captured in Varenne and then they're
sent back to Paris to essentially to be
in house arrest and the twill erease
this is a building right here it doesn't
exist anymore but if you go to Paris and
if you visit the Louvre you'll see kind
of the lube opens across the street into
the twill eree garden this is where that
building used to be so the Royals end up
in house arrest house arrest at the
twill erease this was in June then in
July then in July in 1791 once again all
review from the last video people said
hey they tried to escape
that's equivalent to abdication of the
throne they don't even want to be our
King Queen and we don't need kings and
queens to begin with so the most radical
elements the most radical leftist
elements in particular the jacobins the
jacobins
they started getting petitions they
started getting petitions in the shop
damar to essentially get people say we
don't need a royalty anymore we just
need a
like we need a state without without a
kings and queens but then the the
National Assembly sent in some troops
things got ugly rocks were thrown shots
were fired 50 people died and you have
the Shump damar massacre so then you
have the sharm
chump damar massacre so things are
really really heating up and then we saw
at the end of 1791 to not make things
even worse or not even at the end in
August August we had the pill the
declaration of pillnitz declaration of
pillnitz which we saw was the essential
the rulers of Austria and Prussia saying
that they don't like what's happening to
the Royals in France and for obvious
reasons well one the ruler the the
leopold ii was the brother of marie
antoinette but even more profound they
didn't like this notion of people rising
up against royalty that might give
people in their own empires or in their
own countries ideas about what to do
with them so this this even though this
might have not been taken seriously this
was just a declaration by these guys
this made people in France even more
paranoid now while all of this was
happening you might have remembered that
Tennis Court Oath that occurred several
years ago where they said we promised to
do make to create a constitution and so
a constitution does get created so in
1791 there is actually a constant the
National Assembly or the Constituent
Assembly actually does create a
constitution create a constitution of
1791 which establishes France as a
constitutional monarchy so they're
saying I will still have a king but
it'll be more of a of a a you know it'll
be it'll be kind of more of a figurehead
not that's not only someone who can
create laws the National Assembly will
be responsible for that
the king will get a few abilities to
veto legislation and whatnot but most of
their powers are removed so this was a
constitutional monarchy
constitutional constitute that a little
bit neater constitutional monarchy and
its really along the lines of what was
already going on in Great Britain but
this on some levels it's a major
achievement you know they had that oath
to create a constitution but on a whole
other level things are getting so ugly
in France and in particular in Paris the
Revolution was really focused on what
was going on in Paris and Versailles
things were getting so ugly that this is
starting to become a sideshow and to
some degree the revolutionaries have
gone beyond wanting just a
constitutional monarchy they're starting
to think about wanting a republic we saw
that when during the Shump de Mar
massacre people started signing
signatures to actually have a republic
and then they were fired on which
probably makes them want to have a
republic even more now the other thing
you might remember from the very first
video is the thing that really
precipitated this whole revolution or at
least in my mind one of the main things
that precipitated this whole revolution
is that France France was broke France
was broke and people are going hungry
this is happening the whole time while
all of these politicians and
revolutionaries and royalties are moving
around and trying to kind of strategize
their petition position this is still no
one has solved either of these problems
the entire time there is no money in
France there is a famine people are
going hungry and so pretty much everyone
whether you look at louis xvi
let me look at him again it's always
nice to remember what he looked like
whether you're talking about louis xvi
who's now in house arrest or whether
you're talking about many of the
revolutionaries everyone starts to say
gee how can we solve this problem people
are going to throw us out if we don't
solve this problem of hunger and being
broke so as you'll see in history many
times the best solution for that or the
perceived Vestal solution is to start a
war so they declare war declare war on
Austria and if you think about it from
Louis the sixteenth point of view he
thought of it as kind of a win-win
situation if the war is successful
he kind of threw his weight behind the
war and this happened let me write down
the dates that always helps me frame
where it has this this is now so this
was this is kind of ending 1791 and then
war is declared in April this is now
1792 1792 and then this right here is in
April and if you think about it this was
a win-win or at least from Louis the
sixteenth point of view it was a win-win
if they did well in the war it might
make him more popular might make him
stronger they might be able to plunder
the wealth of other countries to help I
guess get some to build France's coffee
if the war goes badly and France loses
then what's going to happen then you're
going to have Austria and probably the
other people here at war with we'll see
it's very quickly France is going to be
at war with most of the powers of Europe
but if if you lose the war these powers
which are controlled by monarchs they're
going to essentially get rid of the
revolutionaries and probably put louis
xvi back in power so far early the
sixteenth point of view is a good idea
and for a lot of the revolutionaries
they wanted to solve these two problems
so they said hey yeah that would be good
if we could plunder other countries if
you could steal grain from other
countries to make at least the french
less hungry and maybe we can spread the
revolution we can we can topple all of
these other kings that this won't just
be a french revolution that this will be
all of europe revolution so we declared
war on Austria very quickly they tried
to attack the Austrian Netherlands they
tried to attract the Austrian
Netherlands which was kind of disjoint
from the rest of Austria so they
attacked right there into the Austrian
Netherlands although they got kind of
bogged down there wasn't as successful
as they thought it would be and Prussia
which as you remember participated in
the declaration of pillnitz decided to
enter the war on the side of Austria so
prussia prussia attacks and at first
it's pretty pretty successful it's able
to make some headway into france and
then the the general in charge of the
prussian army the duke of brunswick the
duke of brunswick he makes the
Brunswick manifesto let me write that
down
Bruns Wyck manifesto which is
essentially just like the declaration of
pillnitz but it has a lot more teeth
behind it now because this dude the duke
of brunswick he's actually he's got an
army invading France and he declares his
manifesto is saying I intend to
overthrow this whole revolutionary
government and I intend to install the
King again install install the King all
of this happened in April of 1790 to
declare war on Austria seemed like a
win-win for the King the revolutionaries
wanted to spread the Revolution and
plunder other countries and then
immediately Prussia jumps in starts
attacking France and says we're going to
install the King so you could imagine
this is making the revolutionaries even
more paranoid about what the king is up
to they think that the king has some
type of secret deal with the Prussians
or with the other with the with the
enemies that they're going up against so
in August of 1792 there's only a few
months later what four or five months
later in August of 1792 you essentially
have this the commune of Paris and they
say kommune of Paris is really the
government of Paris at this time and
it's been taken over by even more
revolutionary people mainly jacobins and
they storm where the royal family is
staying at the Tuileries
so storming storming let me write your
storm storm twee laries Tuileries which
is that building right here and this
painting right here is a depiction of
the revolutionaries that mainly Jacobins
who are actually storming the Tuileries
and they imprison louis xvi and marine
Marie Antoinette because they're really
you know they're like hey the the
Prussians have already declared they
have an army and they've already
declared the intention to install the
King we're going to imprison the King
because we don't know what he's up to so
they imprison imprison I'm my spelling
in prison louis xvi and Marie Antoinette
and they're also able to do some mashin
nations within the actual National
Assembly and there's actually a rump
session of the National Assembly which
means that a lot of the opponents
weren't there so it was a session where
it was mainly the leftist the radicals
the jacobins were there and in so an
August at that rump session they declare
so the Assembly declares a republic
declares a republic which is equivalent
to saying that louis xvi is no longer
king and this this nation we have or
this this country we now have will never
have a king it is now a republic it is a
government without a king and while all
of this was happened you have these
gangs kind of going around the region
around paris and they're just trying and
killing people that just seem to be
suspicious seem to be seem to be allied
some way so in some way with the
nobility or with the king or in some way
are royalist they want eventually for
the monarchy to come back and in that
kind of in those those riots and those
arbitrary executions and killings they
actually ended up killing over 1,400
people 1,400 executed at this time so
you can see things are getting uglier
and uglier and uglier King is imprisoned
and you're going to see that he's not
going to be imprisoned long but it's not
going to end well for him and
essentially the revolutionaries have
said France is now Republic all while
they're at war with two major powers
with the Austrians
and the Prussian now the they are
eventually able to hold off they are
able to eventually hold off and I'll
tell you say damned I'm talking with the
armies of France they are eventually
able to hold off the invading Prussian
army they call it the stalemate of Omni
not not clear who won the Prussians
weren't that eager to go into France so
they kind of just you know they didn't
push too hard or send too many more
troops so for at least temporarily the
external threat was diffused if you want
to call it that way
and so the National Assembly went forth
and said they got rid of I mean they had
already declared a republic but they
went even further
so this is now we're in September we're
in September of 1792 you had the
stalemate at vol me stalemate at balmy
capitalize that balmy and then the
National Assembly or the National
Convention said hey we're going to make
create a new constitution so that
constitution of 1791 did not last too
long it lasted about a year so new
constitution the intent to create a new
constitution now while all that said
this you know this this bloodshed that
we saw as after they imprisoned louis
xvi these kind of riots in paris and
these arbitrary killings this is just a
foreshadowing of much worse that's going
to come in the very next year by 1793
1793 let me write this down in a bloody
color so 1793 were in now so the
National Assembly they the first thing
that they do or maybe I should say even
more particular in January of 1793 so
we're in January right now remember
they've already deposed the king they
have them imprisoned where they're at
war with these other countries that have
stated the intention to put the King
back into power so the first thing they
do is they execute execute Louis Louie
the sixteenth and this is a picture of
the execution he was guillotined
and this right here is doctor guillotine
and it was actually invented this right
here is the guillotine that right there
is the guillotine and it was actually
invented as a more humane way to kill
people that they at the time they said
hey you know it's very it's very we when
we kill people it's not for them to feel
pain it's more to just kill them so we
use this very humane instrument called
the guillotine where you use a blade to
very quickly chop off someone's head and
it was invented by this physician right
here but the one of the first people
that got to you know
Fortin people they got to try it out was
louis xvi guillotined in january and
then in february remember i mean people
are still going hungry that they're
still eager to spread the revolution
they still want to plunder other other
countries so in February in February the
National Assembly or the National
Council of the Revolutionary Government
declares war on Britain war on Britain
and the Dutch Republic and Dutch let me
not write I don't you don't know who
this is you I'm going to tell you in a
second and Dutch Republic now you're
probably saying gee you know how does
France you know this one country right
here how does France right here how is
it able to have war against Austria
Prussia now declaring war against the
Dutch in Great Britain and actually the
month before Spain and Portugal had
declared war had kind of jumped in on
the side of Austrian Prussia so how does
this one country France how does this
one Revolutionary Government fend itself
off against the armies of so many
nations and the answer to that is that
the Revolutionary Government declared in
February what they called the levy and
mass and I'm not French so I'm saying it
wrong I'm sure the levy in mass which
was essentially the first version of
what we now call the draft and they were
able to actually they actually said
every able-bodied young man in France
who was unmarried will now be in the
army and so they were able to
immediately raise several hundreds of
thousands of soldiers and actually
within a couple of years they were
approaching there's several accounts of
it but it might have been you know over
1 million plus soldiers which is very
different from how many of these other
kingdoms would raise their armies they
would pay salaries to professional
soldiers so these at the time were
smaller armies than what France was able
to muster up through the Revolutionary
Government saying look this is a
government for the people by the people
so now you're not fighting for a king
you're fighting for yourself you're
fighting for your own representation so
you don't get
did by foreign kings so everyone jumped
in the war effort so they essentially
had the largest army in Europe but I
keep repeating all of this was in the
context of you know unrest throughout
France there were Royalists out there
wanting to be counter revolutionaries
people were going hungry so to kind of I
guess clamp down on things in in April
of 1792 so now we're in April the
National Assembly they create the
Committee of Public Safety which sounds
like a very nice committee so Committee
of Public Safety
so public safety and they essentially
become the default government or we
could say the de facto the de facto
government and it was put into control
of this nice-looking gentleman right
here maximilian robes pierre seems like
a very civilized fellow maximilian robes
pierre but really what the public what
the what the Committee of Public Safety
was good at was being hugely political
hugely paranoid and under especially
this you know maximilien robespierre is
control who was especially paranoid
anyone if they just caught a whiff of
someone being not radical enough or or
maybe too radical or someone I just
didn't like or someone who might help
depose me
they just started getting people so this
is really the start of the reign of
terror the reign of terror so over the
next roughly over the next year over
although on the order of give or take 16
thousand people are guillotined they go
to dr. guillotines humane invention and
oh and and there are only estimates of
this there wasn't good accounting of
this but it's believed that as many as
40,000 people were some early executed
which essentially means you're guilty of
this I know you're guilty hey you over
there with the gun please shoot this
person for me so this was an extremely
bloody time in
just so you imagine I mean most of this
was occurring in and around Paris so all
of a sudden in one little city I mean it
was a major city but you have tens of
thousands of people being massacred just
in just if this guy or the people who
are plotting with this guy or the people
were plotting against this guy thought
or caught a whiff of you being not
completely loyal to the revolution now
eventually people be eventually got
suspicious of maximilien robespierre
they're saying hey while your paranoia
is hurting the revolution more than
helping it so then in the thermidorian
reaction which sounds very I know it
sounds like it's some type of a a a
refrigerator heater so thermidorian
Dorian reaction now this right here this
is in July this is in July of 1794 it's
called the thermidorian reaction I might
do a whole video on this because the
revolution the revolution of government
extricated a new calendar where they
renamed the month
thermador was essentially July it was
shifted a little bit and actually
changed the number of hours in the day
they would have 10 hours a day hundred
minutes an hour 100 seconds a minute
they would have three 10-day weeks per
month so they had this whole calendar
but Thermidor was the month of July so
it was really the July reaction where
people got sick of maximilien
robespierre so in 1794 July 1794 he - so
what goes around comes around so this
right here is this is 1794 July this
right here is this nice-looking
gentleman and he too gets guillotined
now there's two other things that I want
to point out I'll take a few steps back
back into 1793 just as a maybe of a bit
of a footnote we saw that in january
louis xvi was executed on for a for I
guess you know depending on your opinion
whether it was a good or a bad thing in
October in October October Marie
Antoinette also executed Marie
and Toinette so this is in 1793 also
executed so nine months after her
husband executed and then as one kind of
small footnote at this point as you can
imagine and all of all of France was in
unrest at the time and then in 1793
there was a revolt this is in July of
1793 so it's a year before the end of
the reign of terror really during the
reign of terror in the port of Toulon
there was a revolt against the
Revolutionary Government and it was put
down mainly with the help of a aspiring
artillery captain artillery captain to
someone who's essentially in charge in
charge of the cannons and that artillery
cannon a captain who was able to help
put down that revolt and get a lot of I
guess cred with the Revolutionary
Government his name was I need to write
it someplace nice and new and this is
foreshadowing of the next video but so
in July of 1793 in Toulon a new
artillery captain started to look like
he really knows what he's doing and his
name is Napoleon Napoleon Bonaparte and
he's going to have a lot to do with the
next video